hey chin bring up that article that uh
marcellus bennett was talking about
you know have do you know him at all
i've met him a couple times smart dude
yeah and him and his brother smart dude
i've done a show with him
he's just one of those smarter minds to
play in the nfl
so he went on this tweet because it says
brandon marshall says he wants to fight
deante wilder
uh he and deonta well and i'm sorry
brandon marshall goes all out box
and out class him insane yeah
i don't know uh uh then uh martellus
bennett put a retired six-time pro
ballers can get knocked out too
laughing and then he goes on to put uh
honestly football made me such an angry
person
everything bothered me uh football's
interesting psychology
psychologically it's some it's some
really dangerous [ __ ]
to really play the game of football you
have to have some [ __ ] up
wiring in your head it's chaotic it
takes years and years of brainwashing
to go along with a lot of [ __ ] hello it
started at peewee that's why you gotta
watch who's coaching your kids
and what they're teaching them beyond
the game i
put uh we're groomed at a young age to
care a little less about
humans uh if you're the backup and the
main
man in front of you goes down you kind
of get excited but feel bad at the same
time shit's crazy
this part made me laugh because it's
true but most of these coaches aren't
good men
most of them are egotistical small dick
heroes
they love the spotlight just as much as
the players and they'd be dumb
it's so true i met some dumbass coaches
when i thought back on that
uh then he goes on you know and this is
his perspective yeah but most your
favorite players aren't good people like
for real for real he goes there are some
good dudes
though john kitten probably one of the
best people i've ever met he's up there
with tom hanks
[Applause]
but he dropped some gems here he goes
the constant reminder of who used to be
by the fans and trophies and highlights
and family as you're trying to
transition to the new uh you really
slows down your process
also starting over shedding the ego
starting over you've made to the top is
hard it's hard to become a nobody after
you are somebody
also guys should prepare their families
for retirement life after football
because everyone's retiring
because football is truly family when
you're a player or coach
the other thing that i've taught guys
they is no longer being a part of the
locker room
so not being part of the locker room
understand that a lot of people weren't
really their friend
it's just proximity that brought up the
closeness really hurts athletes after
all you've been through you would think
we'd be friends forever put your body on
the line for these dudes this team
you all shower together cry together
been around each other's kids
when you're no longer on the team that
bond can be broken quickly
also no longer being famous quote
unquote some guys need that stardom
well they don't need it but they crave
it how could you not it's been a drug
since childhood
you've been a star for forever but how
can you shine without the game
it's interesting right but how can you
shine without the game that's that's
what
we were talking about when you only
identify yourself as that what do you
have when that's taken away from you
again that's his perspective
right you know it's a little uh
biased perspective i you know i don't
know his journey but i'm realizing so
you know i'm almost 44
and and you know you see those old guys
that are grumpy and say you know those
kids don't resp
like no i'm not saying that like he's
turning into that but you kind of feel
like that when you
you know when when you when you don't
have perspective and the truth is
all of us the world humanity is evolving
and the younger generation
you know they're going to benefit from
the things that that we did yeah things
that we struggled and to me
that's not something to feel bitter
about that's something to be that's
something to be proud of
yeah and he had a good correct 10 year
career like he had a great career as a
tight end he was a stud player at texas
a m
so you know the things that football let
him experience engage
and there's there's something to be said
like you can't all be bad it's not but
it just
it's the way that it ends when people
and i say like i took a lot of slack for
it
but i i woke up halfway in in my career
and i was like wait a minute
i was like wait a minute what's going on
and i remember when i was a kid
i wanted to play football to have a
voice and i realized
i've lost my voice because i'm a
football player people put me in
in a box and they don't take what i say
seriously and all they you know is like
run [ __ ] run they just want me to
score touchdowns on on sundays and yeah
i was like
that doesn't feel that doesn't feel good
for to my soul and so that's why i
walked away and i said
i got to find something something else
to be passionate about
otherwise i want to go crazy yeah and
one of the pioneers man because
not so much in the nfl guys even now
stay pretty quiet yeah but in the nba
they're pretty loud yeah that's
nba's loud that's wonderful to see these
past couple years nba really
you know when i was a kid i idolized jim
brown i didn't see him play in person
obviously because i'm not that old but
yeah
but i idolized him not because of only
what he did on the field but he used i
keep talking about a platform he used
his
uh to have a voice and he was saying
some really radical things at a time
where
where i think african americans in
sports were came together and and used
their voice to have some pull and think
think who he you know kind of parlayed
you know the network of muhammad ali
malcolm x
jim brown you're talking about the the
heavy hitters back there cream after
yeah trying to make a change his his is
dicey with jim brown and
you know no one wants to talk about you
know you're talking about
he he had that platform he had a voice
he's trying to make a change but they
also had those domestic
violence issues which were you know was
kind of
but the scar it was but this is this
is real like you know if we go back and
i think we it's so
it's so easy to forget to forget history
and it doesn't mean
make it okay but we're we're evolving
out of that history you know and there
was a time where
it was customary to to do that correct
god like as humans
we're we're we're waking up and we're
and we're going out and realizing that
yeah right you know i i agree with you
yeah i agree you know
and they want to cancel like these old
actors like you know clint eastwood and
these other guys who
had some you know bad stuff back then i
mean we're all a product of our time you
know yeah in 50 years people will be
looking back at us and
saying the same thing yeah
it's true yeah it's true we can have
compassion maybe you know
the future will have we'll have
compassion for us yeah and but i i think
we're not going to get to compassion or
understanding if you just want to cancel
somebody else's exact stuff it's true
it's like whoa whoa whoa you got to
realize the context the times you know
it's just a different arena yeah
it doesn't solve anything yeah no if you
cancel them then then
those new guys are going to be scared to
speak out or speak their mind so they
they just keep everything inside yeah
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son